after years and years of vilifying
millionaires socialist gadfly Bernie
Sanders prepares finally to release his
tax returns and guess what
turns out he's a millionaire we will
analyze why socialists always seem to be
so interested in accumulating wealth
then Candace Owens humiliates Democrats
ted Lieu and Jerry Nadler during
congressional testimony Bibi Netanyahu
wins an historic third term in Israel
Elon omar says more awful things and the
bloom is off the peak but a gugga go
rose I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
wait until you hear
Bernie's explanation for why it's okay
that he's a millionaire but it's not
okay that other people are millionaires
I actually have a personal connection to
Bernie's explanation and I can tell you
it is not really cutting it it's not
really that convincing but first let's
make a little bit of money honey with
expressvpn admit it you think that
cybercrime is something that happens to
other people you may think that no one
wants your data hackers can't rabi your
passwords or credit card details but you
would be wrong
stealing data from unsuspecting people
on public Wi-Fi is one of these simplest
and cheapest ways for hackers to make
money when you leave your internet
connection unencrypted you may as well
be writing your passwords and credit
card numbers on a huge billboard for the
rest of the world to see that's why I
decided to take action to protect myself
from cyber criminals I have expressvpn
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
expressvpn has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone and tablet turning on
expressvpn protection only takes one
click using expressvpn I can safely surf
on public Wi-Fi with that being snooped
on or having my personal data stolen for
less than seven bucks a month you can
get the same expressvpn protection that
I've got expressvpn is rated the number
one VPN service by TechRadar comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantee protect
your online activity today find out how
you can get three months free it
expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH AE l
that's exp or ESS v PM comm slash
michael for three months free with one
year package visit expressvpn comm slash
michael mi CH AE l to learn more the
time finally comes for Bernie Sanders to
come clean if you had to describe Bernie
Sanders's campaign Bernie Sanders's
entire political career in just one word
how would you describe it
billionaire billionaire millionaires
billionaires millionaires and
billionaires at the same time
billionaires of millionaires and
billionaires millionaires in
billionaires millionaires and
billionaires millionaire a billionaire
millionaires and billionaires
billionaires and millionaires he enough
is enough enough is enough Bernie enough
of the lies guess what it turns out
Bernie Sanders is a millionaire of
course he's a millionaire he did an
interview with the New York Times and he
says that now as he's preparing to run
for president 2020 he is finally going
to release ten years worth of his tax
returns now you might say Michael Bernie
Sanders ran in 2016
they all made such an issue about the
tax returns surely Bernie Sanders has
already released his tax returns right
wrong no no no as with everything when
it comes to socialism it's always
different rules for you than they are
for me tax returns for thee but not for
me so Bernie Sanders Wow while he's been
running for president now since what
2015 basically non-stop he has released
not even one tax return he released a
two-page summary of one year of his tax
returns that's all we know about
Bernie's tax returns right now by the
way I don't care about tax returns I
don't care at all what any of the
candidates have done in their tax
returns it does not interest me in the
least
I don't think candidates should release
their tax returns
there's just no reason for it now why
don't I care I don't care because I
don't care if you're really wealthy and
want to run for office I think that's a
noble thing that you've made a lot of
money and they decide that you're going
to stop making money for a period of
time you're actually gonna lose some
money to serve your country I think
that's a wonderful thing I don't ever
discourage rich people from running for
office now for the Democrats of course
for especially for socialists like
Bernie Sanders they ostensibly hate when
wealthy people run for office they're
oligarchs they're millionaires they're
billionaires until it turns out that
you're one of those millionaire
billionaire plutocrat oligarchs as well
aren't you Bernie so now the Democrats
have made tax returns a big deal Bernie
Sanders is in
this corner he has to release his tax
returns so he's now trying to let it
leak a little bit slowly bernie is a
millionaire
I always knew Bernie was a millionaire
there were a number of reasons in a very
personal way I know that Bernie Sanders
has three houses is three homes it's
hard to have three homes if you're not a
millionaire I guess by definition you're
a millionaire especially where Bernie
Sanders is living if you have three
homes but the excuse is what's really
incredible so he says I'm a millionaire
yes I'm a millionaire
quote I wrote a best-selling book if you
write a best-selling book you can be a
millionaire too first of all by the way
I have to say not to tell tales out of
school or anything I did write a
best-selling book I wrote a number one
best-selling book it was number one on
Amazon total charts everywhere for a
week and a half I haven't made a million
dollars on that book Bernie Sanders has
made more money on his books than I have
now I assume his books were just bought
by various Democrat political action
committees and that sort of thing to
float his presidential campaign but
still the statement he made is not true
I wrote a breast selling book have you
read a best-selling book you can be a
millionaire too I guess you can be but
how come that's okay for Bernie but it's
not okay for other people
how come it's okay when Bernie makes a
million dollars on the private market or
in the open market rather in private
enterprise but it's not okay when other
people do it's okay if you write a
best-selling book then it's okay to be a
millionaire but if you start a company
that makes widgets then it's not okay to
be a millionaire if you're a plumber who
has a successful plumbing company then
it's not okay to be a millionaire if you
work in finance and you add liquidity to
markets then it's not okay to be a
millionaire any other field it's not
okay it's terrible the millionaires are
destroying this country too many
millionaires and billionaires unless you
write a best-selling book what is it
about best-selling books let me tell you
something there are a lot of
best-selling books most of them are
completely worthless Bernie Sanders's
book is completely worthless he has
added very little to society by
producing that book he's probably just
damaged some forests by wasting trees
does anyone
really believe that Bernie Sanders's
book has made a greater contribution to
society has improved the lives of people
more than the car company or the vacuum
cleaner company or any of the other
companies any enterprise that allows
people to thrive and buy goods and
services for their friends and family
that's an amazing excuse so I knew
Bernie was a millionaire I mean I knew
he wrote the book so I knew he was a
millionaire but moreover I knew Bernie
was a millionaire because he just he
just protests a little too much about
socialism this is the funny thing with
socialism the other we were talking
about this I was talking to sweet little
Elise about this and she said but Mac if
Bernie's a big socialist shouldn't he
give away all of his money
of course he should sweet sweet sweet
little Alisa of course you're thinking
to rationally you're thinking to
logically you're accepting the premises
of socialists at face value and
following their ideas to a logical
conclusion that's not what socialism is
about at all that is certainly not what
socialism is about socialism is not
about giving away wealth socialism is
about the acquisition of wealth it is
never about sharing wealth they're
sharing wealth is called charity people
who want to share their wealth give
money away to charity they give it to
the bum on the street they give it to
their church they give it to nonprofit
organizations and charities socialism is
about accumulation it's about the
accumulation of wealth and the
accumulation of power it's about saying
ooh too many people have too many things
out there we are going to not give
anything away we're going to take that
wealth away from them and concentrate it
in the hands of a small number of people
also known as the government that's
socialism conservatives think there is
some contradiction with millionaire
socialists no of course a socialist is
going to be a millionaire all a
socialist is concerned with is taking
money bringing in money accumulating
money you'll notice most of the people
who are pushing socialism or extremely
wealthy Bernie Sanders is a millionaire
all of the leaders of the damage
at party are millionaires Hillary
Clinton multi multimillionaire huge
slush funds raises you basically used a
nonprofit organization as a personal
slush fund how about Alexandria cassia
Cortes she's just 29 years old she was a
bartender living in her parents house
not 3 years ago and she is already she's
been in government for two months she's
already a taking 1 million dollars out
of her campaign and funneling it to her
own uses she is already embezzling a
million dollars she's been in office for
two months that's what socialism does
it's it's about taking in bringing in
that's not even an irony we know it from
the beginning this is what this is what
Winston Churchill said he said that
socialism is the philosophy of failure
the creative ignorance and the gospel of
envy it's all about greed it's not about
charity at all if you like charity then
you give to charity you you actually
don't want someone stealing your money
because you know that they're not going
to put it too nearly as good a use as
you are going to put it to socialism
at no point engages the faculties of
charity or empathy or generosity not
none of those things it exclusively
engages avarice greed and envy and
acquisitiveness the great example Dinesh
D'Souza used to use this example all the
time if I'm walking along the street I'm
walking on the sidewalk here and I see
some bum and he's some just degenerate
drug addled lazy bum and he I'm eating a
sandwich and he says hey can I have can
I have that sandwich I like my sandwich
I've got my sandwich here but I say you
know here here's half my sandwich now I
am glad that I have done some charity
I've treated you with compassion you
have a gratitude toward me because I've
given you a sandwich that I didn't need
to give you and there's a nice moral
exchange that happened on the flip side
I'm walking down the street do to do to
do eating my sandwich then millionaire
Bernie Sanders comes up on his white
horse and he points a gun at my head and
he says give him that sandwich say you
give him your sandwich
you're the millionaire you give him a
say no no yo you'll give him your
sandwich right now so then I got to give
the bum my sandwich I resent the bum for
taking my sandwich
I certainly resent Bernie Sanders for
making me do it the bum isn't grateful
to me the bomb I guess is sort of
grateful or at least dependent on Bernie
Sanders and he's he feels entitled to my
sandwich
his only attitude toward me is one of
entitlement as though he deserves my
sandwich and Bernie Sanders it cost him
nothing millionaire Bernie that's
socialism for you and Bernie is exposing
it and by the way it is not going to
change one single voters calculation
people who think ha ha yes now Bernie is
exposed as a millionaire yes this will
show that he is a hypocrite no it won't
in a narrow way it will but socialists
don't care about that
socialists do not want to share the
wealth socialists want to take the
wealth and Bernie is a prime example of
that take the wealth by any means
necessary even if it means contradicting
your public statements for 40 years when
the leftists are not exposing themselves
as Bernie Sanders is doing Candice Owens
is doing it for them Candice Owens
testified our friend Candice we've had
around the show number of times she
testified before Congress yesterday it
was so beautiful she was testifying on
white nationalism might say that's a
little strange why's Candice Owens
testifying on white nationalism of all
the well I think it was a masterstroke
by Republicans she can tell you why she
did it but the the question of white
nationalism is totally ginned up by
Democrats what is white nationalism what
is it a white nationalism actually does
have a meaning it means that you
advocate for a white ethnic state and
it's specifically in America that's a
white nationalism in America means okay
that has a specific meaning you want a
white
State depends on exactly the definition
of white but broadly speaking we know
what we mean by white people you want a
white ethnic state you want everybody
else to leave how many people in this
country actually advocate for that like
five maybe a dozen people in this
country how many people actually are
advocating for a white ethnic state and
the deportation of everybody else in the
country
nobody virtually nobody and
statistically nobody in this country is
advocating that it is not a problem it
is a non-issue except the Democrats need
to make this an issue so the Democrats
are using this phrase all the time I am
Telling You white nationalism actually
does have a precise meaning except in
our popular culture today it has no
meaning it has been totally robbed of
meaning whenever anybody says it to you
it means nothing it means why you're a
meanie you're bad you're bad you're bad
it's the new racist racist used to have
a meeting now it doesn't white
supremacists used to have a meaning now
it doesn't because they call everybody
to the right of Hillary Clinton a white
nationalist or a white supremacist or a
white racist or this or that or the
other thing ilan Omar called Stephen
Miller a white nationalist Steven Miller
I will remind you is a Jew white
nationalists generally speaking not huge
fans of the yarmulke
but she'll call Stephen Miller a white
nationalist and why does she do that cuz
what she what you really mean by white
nationalists when the left uses it is
somebody with whom I disagree on
basically anything that's white
nationalism so they bring this term up
they've made this term very popular
they've been popularizing it a lot since
2016 and they bring Candace Owens before
Congress Democrats did not know what hit
them when the tornado of Candace Owens
tore through the Capitol there isn't a
single adult today that in good
conscience would make the argument that
America is a more racist or a more
nationalist society that it was when my
grandfather was growing up and yet we're
hearing these terms sent around today
because what they want to say is that
brown people need to be scared which
seems to be the narrative that we hear
every four years right ahead of a
presidential election here are some
things we never hear 75 percent of the
black boys in California don't meet
state reading standards in inner cities
like Baltimore within five high schools
in one middle school not a single
student was found to be proficient in
math or reading in 2016 the single who
mother would the single motherhood rate
in the black community which is that 23
percent in the 1960s and my grandfather
was coming up with a staggering 74
percent today I am guessing there will
be no committee hearings about that
there are more black babies born there
are more black babies aborted than born
alive in cities like New York and you
have Democrat Governor Andrew Cuomo
lighting up buildings to celebrate late
term abortions I could go on and on my
point is that white nationalist right
nationals does not do any of those
things that I just brought up Democrat
policies did let me be clear the hearing
today is not about white nationalism or
hate crimes it's about fear mongering
power and control absolutely devastating
and such a brilliant tactic so she
acknowledges the issue here which is
that white nationalism barely exists in
America it is virtually non-existent as
an ideology in the United States they're
holding a big hearing because Democrats
want to pretend the donald trump is some
anti black bigot or anti-hispanic bigot
or whatever she goes up and she doesn't
just refute their argument she doesn't
just say no but it's not because of this
because of this and know it and then
Trump did this and see so it's not that
no what Candis understands is what
Ronald Reagan used to say which is that
when you're explaining you're losing in
a political battle in a political debate
when you are explaining you're
explaining yourself away you are losing
so what she does is she goes on the
attack she says why is it the case
that out of wedlock births single
motherhood among black Americans was
twenty three twenty five percent decades
ago now it's seventy four percent why is
that white nationalisms fault why is it
that in in New York City today more
black babies are killed in the womb than
are born and white liberals are cheering
on that policy
oh they're donating millions to Planned
Parenthood kill those black babies we
don't want too many of those young poor
black babies running around kill all
that what is that white nationalism or
is that the policy of the Democrat Party
and is that the policy of leftists is
that white gnash I don't think so
she goes on and on obviously she could
go on and on and on
Thomas Sol has written several books on
this exact point which I suspect is
where she got her arguments from and and
Candis has all of the rhetorical
abilities to convey this message she
obviously is black she has a certain
ethos here she has a certain credibility
because she's speaking from the black
experience in America she has the pathos
she's she's very good at connecting
emotionally to people and she has the
logical side of the argument - she's
just pointing to statistics she's
pointing to different periods of history
she's showing before and after and she's
saying what's the difference is the
difference the Ku Klux Klan is the
difference David Duke is the difference
Richard Spencer or is the difference
left-wing policies from the federal
government from the federal level all
the way on down and particularly
accentuated in cities that are run by
left-wing Democrats such as New York
brilliant opening totally shuts it down
and she just comes out swinging she's
just punching punching punching so now
the Democrats are on their toes they
don't they did not expect this so now
they start to go after her the biggest
scandal was my
sentence in American politics is that
Democrats have been conning minorities
into belief that we are perpetual
victims all but insuring our failure
racial division and class warfare are
central to the democrat party platform
and he blacks to hate whites the rich to
hate the poor and soon enough it'll be
the tall hating the short oh my gosh we
didn't some will get to the Democrats
hitting her in a second that last line
that is they want the blacks to hate the
whites they want the rich to hate the
poor and the poor to hate the rich they
want that tall to hate this short they
want to divide everybody in it's
Democrats who have done it she is taking
the fight right to them she's not
speaking in nice polite political
campaign terms she is speaking in blunt
terms this is a lesson that a lot of
people can learn from Donald Trump
before that they could learn it from
Ronald Reagan actually Ronald Reagan
spoke in blunt terms he spoke actually
in these exact terms he said well we've
gotten to a point in our society where
I'm paraphrasing obviously we've gotten
to a point in our society where you
can't look at a rich fat man and a
skinny man and not think that the fat
man got that way by taking from the
skinny man well Nancy I don't get fed on
jelly beans that this was from a time
for choosing right not the jelly bean
part this is from Ronald Reagan's most
famous address it's what launched him as
a national political figure and canvas
is learning this exact rhetorical lesson
and that that end by the way she has the
advantage of being correct
so she's right about that point on
Democrats so now the Democrats they just
have to use everything they've got on
her the one thing they've got is that
one of these campus speaking events
Candis Owens was asked a question about
nationalism and Nazism and Hitler and is
isn't if you're a nationalist aren't you
a a Hitler supporter and so Candace
Owens here draws a distinction between
nationalism and Nazism and this went
viral it was taken out of context the
the Democrats honed in on a few words
that were not cautiously arranged to to
try to pretend that Candace Owens is
some Nazi or something
try to pretend that she's defending
Hitler or something like that here here
is the clip that ted Lieu played on his
cell phone
Democrat representative Ted Lou before
the entire committee to try to shut down
Candis Owens with the word nationalism I
think that it gets the definition gets
poisoned by lead us that actually want
globalism globalism is what I what I
don't want so when you think about
whenever we say Nationals and the first
thing people think about in at least in
America is Hitler you know he was a
National Socialist but if Hitler just
wanted to make Germany great and have
things run well okay fine the problem is
is that he wanted he had dreams outside
of Germany he wanted to globalize he
wanted everybody to be German everybody
to be speaking German everybody look a
different way that's not to me that's
not nationalism so in thinking about how
we could go bad down the line I don't
really I don't really have an issue with
that shit'll ism I really don't okay
there it is there's the big line now we
will explain exactly what she was
actually saying in just a second we'll
get to the rest of her excellent
testimony but first you got to go to
daily wire.com you know what you get you
get all the shows the and reclaim show
the ben shapiro show my show the matt
will show you test questions in the
mailbag get those in for thursday you
get to ask questions on backstage you
get another Kingdom you get everything
you get the leftist here's tumblr and
you need this baby before we get to the
rest of Candace's testimony before
Congress you need this tumblr or you
will drown stick around we'll be right
back
okay so ted Lieu plays this this is
supposed to shut it down
oh you saw what Candace said about
Hitler this person hit she talked about
Hitler
what did she actually say let's them
because what ted Lieu wants to do is
they see she said the word Hitler had
she's awful what did she actually say
what she said was the overall point that
she's making is that nationalism is
different from imperialism this is the
point that your Amazonia makes in his
recent book excellent book the virtues
of nationalism she's saying very often
when we use the word nationalism what we
really mean is imperialism and a good
example of this is Hitler in Nazi
Germany because we use nationalism to
describe the Nazi movement but in fact
the movement is better described as an
imperial movement what did they do they
took over Czechoslovakia they took over
Poland they took over Austria they took
they [ __ ] they took over France that it
was entirely about conquest and so what
Candace is saying there is that there is
a difference between those two things
we are reversing the two terms
we're inverting the two terms and
actually what I oppose is imperialism or
globalism which actually better
describes Nazi Germany that's what she's
saying FairPoint now where she misspeaks
where she could have raised her language
better is she said look if Hitler just
wanted to stick around Germany that
would have been fine but it's only
because he tried to expand beyond
Germany that it was bad now what that
statement ignores is of course the
effect of Hitler's policies on religious
and ethnic minorities in Germany itself
yes she missed that she ignored that she
misspoke unless you think the Candace
Owens is advocating for the night of the
Long Knives and let she's advocating for
anti Jew
policies all throughout Germany if she's
advocating for oppressing the Jews and
other minorities in Germany unless you
think that I think you have to conclude
she misspoke she's making a point that
domestic policy is different than
international policy and the issue by
the way she actually sort of addresses
this point later which is that the issue
for Hitler is that the domestic policy
is inextricable from the international
policy the domestic policy is an
international policy it's about
expanding the size of Germany that is
the broader point and by the way when we
think of the essence of the Nazi agenda
what do we think of do we think about
certain policies within Germany No we
think about the international policies
all of Nazism was fueled by imperialist
ambitions when you think of the
Holocaust what do you think of you think
of the smokestacks of Burque now you
think of Auschwitz those those places
are not in Germany those places are in
nazi-occupied Poland some of the worst
most notoriously and Czechia France
Austria the some as far as Ukraine right
some as far as Latvia right those are
quite far away from Germany that is the
point she's making no one on earth
believes the Candace Owens is defending
Hitler and yet this is the best argument
that the Democrats on this committee had
against Candace Owens and she oh I mean
obviously she didn't have time to kind
of explain it as we just did she shuts
this guy down in a way that really only
she can nobody does this better than
Candace Owens someones I'm sorry I we
just started recording
would you like time to respond to that
yes um I think it's pretty apparent that
mr. lube believes that black people are
stupid and will not pursue the full clip
in its entirety he purposely presented
an extract
the extractors lip the way this will
suspend for a moment it is not proper to
refer to spera jingly or with to a
member of the committee the witness will
not do that again
witness may continue sure even though I
was called despicable witness may not
refer to remember the committee is
stupid I didn't refer to him as stupid
that's not what I said
that's not what I said at all you didn't
listen to what I said may I continue
please as I said he is assuming that
black people will not go pursue the full
- our clip and he purposefully extracted
he cut off and you didn't hear the
question that was asked of me he's
trying to present as if I was launching
a defense of Hitler in Germany when in
fact the question that was asked of me
was / turning to whether or not I
believed that Hitler was a whether or
not I believed in nationalism and that
nationalism was bad and when I responded
to is that I do not believe that we
should be characterizing Hitler as a
nationalist oh my gosh he's the best
part of it really so again this is such
a lesson you have to learn this from
Candace
Ted Lou goes up he's got his best shot
he's got this little tight clip where
he's trying to make it look like Candace
Owens is going out giving a speech
defending Hitler and instead of trying
to explain and explain and explain right
away she said well I think it's pretty
apparent that Ted Lou thinks blacks are
stupid I think that's pretty apparent
devastating he also does she's
completely right he is he is assuming
not just that black people are stupid
but they the American people are stupid
he's at least assuming that his
constituents are stupid because they're
not going to go look up the clip they're
stupid or they're lazy I guess is what
he thinks and so she calls him out on
that puts him on the defensive Jerry
Nadler chairman of the committee has to
come out and say no no no I've got to
defend Ted Lou here so he comes and he
says you you can't do that
you can't you can't that's not
appropriate to use words like that
you can't disparage people she says I
was just called despicable are you
talking about
is it appropriate to call a witness
despicable you oh you just can't call a
congress okay he says well you can you
called him stupid hey buster you got you
got wax in your ears
did I call him stupid stupid is as
stupid does Jerry Nadler went show me on
the tape where I called him stupid she
didn't she said Ted Lou clearly thinks
black people are stupid and Nadler said
you can't call Ted lo stupid they know
you have to wonder here is is Jerry
Nadler stupid or is he just being obtuse
is he trying to conflate those two
things and I'm not sure Jerry Nadler is
a local New York politician Jerry Nadler
is not the brightest bulb in the pack
okay his entire career he just came up
through local corruption machine
politics in New York this guy is not not
one of the leading leading lights of
statesmanship we'll put it that way so
he actually may just not understand the
difference if I say that person thinks
that that person is stupid he might not
understand how that is different from
saying you are stupid even though
they're obviously completely different
things but then Candace because she's
really good at this she actually lets
him sit there she's like a good good
prosecutor she she puts him in the place
where he has to answer and she's willing
to tolerate some silence so she goes
that's not what I said you you are
misrepresenting what I say you're lying
about what I said
and then she just sits there silently
staring at him and Nadler is staring
back like you know weebles wobble but
they don't fall down he just looks like
this sad little doll and he just looks
at her and you couldn't see the clip he
just was there he's kind of slumped over
here's goes aren't any kind of just
shrugs ah which is by the way I mean
that actually I guess is the answer to
the question of whether he's being
obtuse or whether he's a little slow is
that actually he's just a cynic he
doesn't care what the truth is that's
what the shrug is she said you are lying
you're lying about what happened not 10
seconds ago and he goes huh what is
truth all right I'll give us Barabbas
all right what is truth that's what
that's what that shrug is that shrug we
did that whole show yesterday on
Democrat BS on what BS means why the
left spews BS it's not that they're
necessarily in tension
lying were intentionally tough they
don't care about the truth huh
and then she goes on yeah you can look
up the rest of it it's a fabulous
exchange she does very very well
some people are nitpicking little points
here and there she should have said this
better she said you know listen you're
under a lot of pressure here to testify
before these committees they're throwing
in her face these little answers
completely out of context from campus
speeches I thought she handled herself
extraordinarily well it really really
was a great advantage to conservatives
around the country great testimony and a
great call by the way from Republicans
on that committee to bring her in to
testify because the thing that people
don't also don't really remember about
her she herself was the victim of what
you would call a hate crime in high
school this was kind of a well attested
to well reported story and then she came
out obviously she's much better known
now for the black soot movement for her
conservative commentary for her
conservative speeches but she really a
plus a plus outing for Candace Owens
really humiliated ted Lieu and Jerry
Nadler two guys who deserved to be
humiliated
speaking of nationalism turning not to
our own nation but to a nation in the
Middle East Bibi Netanyahu wins again in
Israel Bibi Netanyahu wins an historic
fifth term as Prime Minister of Israel
Bibi is the right-wing Prime Minister of
Israel is the image of conservatism in
Israel the image of nationalism in
Israel and we were told he's gonna lose
bee bees going down oh there's no first
of all you think he should at this point
he's already had four terms oh he's
going down the media they were so sure
oh it's gonna be bee bees gonna lose
Trump's gonna lose Hillary's gonna win
oh it's guaranteed guaranteed then they
start reporting all it looks like bee
bees losing bee bees about to lose then
no it's kind of evening out no then both
candidates Bibi Netanyahu and his
opponent Benny Ganz both declare victory
but only
one of them actually gets victory it's a
BB declares victory because he actually
won Bennigan's declares victory because
leftists BS all the time and here is BB
celebrating this evening horn it's an
amazing success that we've had
[Music]
[Applause]
Vicki model and we have come to this
time
big win for baby big win for baby he
goes on but if you don't speak Hebrew
you know it gets a little tedious the
mainstream media tell us that everyone
is so sick of Trump Trump ISM
conservatism nationalism right-wing ISM
they're so sick of it nobody wants that
anymore
there's no way nobody wants Trump nobody
wants Bibi nobody wants any of the
right-wingers have one in Europe then
how come all the right-wing candidates
keep winning house that doesn't it's so
weird because I read about how
everyone's so sick of the right and yet
the right-wingers keep winning at home
and abroad this is another big loss for
the media by the way Bibi Netanyahu
campaigned on Trump and he campaigned
with Trump big photos of him and Trump
smiling big events geared right around
election time with Trump very much
hitching his wagon to Trump and he won
by the way by the way let's not forget
this we talked about collusion talking
about nationalism we talked about
collusion in other people's elections
let's not forget that Barack Obama used
taxpayer money to try to oust Bibi
Netanyahu when he was president not that
he used his own campaign money not that
he used his own personal money Barak
Obama while he was president used
taxpayer funds to try to kick Netanyahu
out of office in Israel where's that
investigation into meddling in people's
elections Barak Obama did a lot more to
meddle in that election than the
Russians did to meddle in the u.s.
elections at least in terms of spending
money on what did the Russians spend a
hundred thousand dollars on Facebook ad
buys Barack Obama spent three hundred
fifty thousand dollars of taxpayer money
through the State Department he funneled
it to a group in Israel called one voice
ostensibly a pro-peace group BS as
always with that group one voice took
350 GS from the American taxpayer use
that money to build a voter database to
train activists
to hire a consulting firm that worked
for Barack Obama in 2008 to hire that
firm to oust Bibi Netanyahu from office
in Israel that's not some crazy
conspiracy theory that's not right-wing
fake news that's not looking down deep
in the Internet that's according to the
Senate Subcommittee on investigations
and still we hear from these BS
Democrats that interference in a foreign
election oh heavens to Betsy let me
clutch my pearls Oh Oh the horror I
can't even imagine oh the collusion oh
my goodness gracious me
oh no and by the way guess what
Netanyahu won Barack Obama used the
force of the most powerful state in the
history of the world and the wealth of
the most prosperous state in the history
of the world to try to oust this guy
from office and Israel and the guy won
and Obama lost and then years later
you'd think people would be tired of
this guy already Bibi Netanyahu wins
running on Trump and with Trump with the
guy who beat Obama he wins an historic
fifth term great great stuff speaking of
the Jews and people who don't like the
Jews we have to mention Ilhan Omar why
do we have to mention her I prefer not
to mention her I don't like her very
much but we have to mention her because
Newsweek just gave her another magazine
cover this is a really an amazing they
all of these freshmen congresswoman who
have accomplished very little in their
lives magazine cover after magazine
cover after magazine cover so she's on
the cover of Newsweek and by the way
this video just surfaced of elon Omar
discussing the September 11th terrorist
attacks here was founded after 9/11
because they recognize that some people
did something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties
Wow first of all I can't believe that
this video hasn't made the rounds before
I guess whoever had dug it up was
waiting on it this marks the first time
a member of Congress has referred to the
September 11th terrorist attacks as some
people did something could we play that
again here was founded after 9/11
because they recognize that some people
did something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties some people did something
3,000 American civilians killed in a
terrorist attack biggest terrorist
attack in the history of the United
States civilians going around just doing
work said goodbye to their kids in the
morning didn't come home some people did
something that woman that horrible
horrible horrible woman is in Congress
some people did something and and it's
even it's even worse than that because
she describes as the victim the victim
of 9/11 according to Ilan Omar is Ilan
Omar she said some people did something
who cares about that that what thing let
them what is it 3,000 people 3,000
American civilians died Oh something
happened and then I lost my civil
liberties by the way no you didn't
you're a member of Congress you didn't
lose any you didn't lose one scintilla
of a civil liberty you lost nothing some
people did something Alon Omar what a
horrible horrible woman I can't
I should stop speaking about her because
I'll say something that maybe I'll
regret or something that is the most
outrageous statement I have ever heard
from an American politician in my
lifetime or in history and I'm a student
of history that is so outrageous to hear
that and this woman is being pushed at
located by the left she's being raised
the cover of glossy magazines
she's a spokesman for the Democrat Party
for the left-wing she's doing it to
defend the Council on american-islamic
relations which has been defined and
categorized by the government of the
United Arab Emirates as a terrorist
group it's got ties for the Muslim
Brotherhood
it's got ties to Hamas there she is
defending terrorists again again she's
done this before she's defended people
who tried to join Isis tried to get them
lenient sentences she defends terrorists
and then she describes the worst
terrorist attack in US history 3,000
American civilians dead as some people
did something behold the Democrat Party
behold the American Left behold the
Democrat Party that's the face of it you
know when you watch candice Owens
speaking giving congressional testimony
you think wow that's what this woman's
really fired up how why she's so fired
up and then you watch her you watch
Ilhan Omar you watch someone say
something like that and you think wow
the stakes really are pretty high wow
there are some really wicked wicked
people saying vicious evil things wicked
things behold the Democrat Party that's
our show I'm flying out to Kansas City
Missouri I'm going to be giving a speech
tomorrow night at University of Missouri
Kansas City come check it out the title
is going to be men or not women you
would think you wouldn't have to defend
this sort of thing these days but you do
because it's 2019 so come check it out
if you're there hopefully we'll be able
to stream it but if you're in town I'd
love to come see you in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael an
old show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
Vera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody's Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the left says
white nationalism is on the rise I say
their real object is silencing
conservative speech we'll talk about
that and we've got the mail bag on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin